her name was flora spread and she lived
on Nova's hill overlooking Baker town
from the window of her flower mill the
bright lights of the city fueled her
longing to create with the innovative
bakers with whom she knew she could
relate she saw the cakes they cooks and
the muffins that they made but she kept
on beating her bread or the wild feeling
for trains but her mother left her in
this mess of yeast flour and dough she
must taste inspiration and stop chewing
the bread of woe
[Music]
whoa
down in fake town loot Victoria sponge
but her cakes just went selling so she
knew that it was time to take a plunge
into the new and see things from her
brand-new of you and yes yoke miss flora
I am talking to you won't you come down
that hill of yours and work here in my
shop you might have to bake until the
ovens pop but I need your creative eye
with my wisdom and your innovation
together we can bake the perfect success
pie III
success pi
[Music]
success pi bread bread
after just one week in that shop
florists business was booming her
creativity blooming and her customers
consuming but looming on the horizon lay
arising problem people couldn't stop
eating and there was nothing that could
stop them what was once people of pretty
balanced diets bacon town without bread
was revolution without Ryan's flora
posters shut down but she knew it was
too late and soon enough the population
of town
was over way AAA ate overweight
over where hey ain't
[Music]
bread bread
and so the very next day flora went back
to Han mill and opened up her bread shop
but it seemed to Flora's dismay that no
one wanted her bread and she was left
alone up on the hilltop Victoria sponge
kept on baking with recipes she stole
from Flora's notes and Flora's heart
kept breaking as the cakes continued
rising and the bread became toes
[Music]